I am pleased to hand over to an incoming
leader of the Conservative Party and
prime minister who I worked with when he
was in my cabinet
[Music]
[Applause]
and who is committed as a conservative
who stood on a conservative manifesto in
2017 to delivering on the vote of the
British people in 2016 and to delivering
a bright future for this country I think
we approach the issues we face in this
country in different ways I have spent
orbit one of my years in this house on
the front bench trying to implement the
policies I believe in
he has spent most of his time on the
back benches campaigning for what he
believes in often against his own party
but what I think we both have in common
is a commitment to our constituencies I
saw that after the terrorist attack in
Finsbury Park mosque in his constituency
and but perhaps I could just finished my
exchange with him by saying this as a
party leader who has accepted when her
time was up perhaps the time is now for
him to do the same in the last three
years child poverty has gone up
pensioner poverty has gone up in work
poverty has gone violent crime has gone
NHS waiting times that have gone up
school class sizes of Ghana homelessness
has gone up
Foodbank use as Ghana does the Prime
Minister have any regrets about any of
those things I've just said I of course
came here in 1997 as one of only 30
conservative women and indeed one Labour
Member of Parliament approached me to
encourage me to sign the private
member's bill list because he assumed as
I was a woman I must have been a Labour
Member of Parliament but I'm also proud
I'm also proud to have played my part in
getting more women MPs in this house and
I'm sure that amongst the women in this
house today there is a future Prime
Minister maybe more than one day today
as I said earlier I will return to the
back benches and it will be my first
time in 21 years so it's going to be
quite a change from standing here at the
despatch-box I'm told that over the last
three years I've answered over 4,500
questions over 140 hours in this house
more more than I might have expected mr.
speaker
in future I look forward to asking the
questions but we are as the right
honorable lady has said living through
extraordinary political times this House
of Commons is rightly at the center of
those events and that's because of the
vital link between every single member
of this house and the communities the
Commons that we represent that's the
bedrock of our parliamentary democracy
and of our Liberty and each one of us
wherever we sit whatever we stand for
can take pride in that and that duty to
serve my constituents will remain my
greatest motivation
[Music]
[Applause]